[Musique]
mais oui vous la voulez bien sur ce
dakar
bonjour je m'appelle agnès la semaine
dernière j'ai regardé la soirée
paranormal et j'ai pas vu grand-chose de
paranormal est ce normal
alors je comprends ces questions
charnière car vous n'êtes pas la seule
visée d'être posée y en avait un moment
oui je sais vous avez beaucoup de gens
ont trouvé la soirée de jeudi très très
drôle très sympa mais sont demandés à
quel rapport avec le paranormal et
surtout pourquoi y avait au mars y et
laurent lafitte en permanence à l'écran
la vérité c'est que vous êtes trompé de
chaîne c'est pas de notre faute c'est
celle de cyril qui la veille avait fait
une bonne pub pour le film de l'autre
côté du périph dû tenir à la soirée
vraiment paranormal ici on dirait sur un
titre fera même demain il y aura la
soirée vraiment paranormal ici en direct
sur un titre on fera même une séance de
spiritisme je vous dis qu'est-ce qui a
bullet c'était sûr c'est évident le
paranormal et il c'est vrai qu'on avait
une séquence incroyable
non mais vraiment dans la soirée un truc
surnaturel on a vu gilles verdez
enthousiaste non mais vraiment on dit
souvent que gilles critique tout qui
n'aime jamais rien et ben là alors on
l'a vu heureux
c'était sans doute la séquence la plus
part anormale de tout le prime alors on
la repasse
ça
ouais
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on y voit pour l'oreille sa part normal
c'était plus compliqué faut dire que
autour de la table il y avait jean
michel mr hyde ce qui n'inquiète pas
quand tu es créer une ambiance
mystérieuse là les chroniqueurs devaient
deviner quel était le don surnaturel qui
avait l'homme aux canettes sur la tête
jean michel avait deux propositions
l'une est passé à l'antenne l'autre pas
non c'est pas ça mais je suis pas sûr je
tente est ce que ce serait pas le zizi
le moule d'hollywood
c'est un non sens plus mes rivales
[Applaudissements]
on laissera la callas non mais c'est
consternant ses côtés jean michel lui
c'est vrai en fait le seul qui a essayé
de créer une atmosphère paranormales
dans toute la soirée c'est cyril s'est
donné à fond comme quand vous avez fait
le médium alors là respect un acteur
studio à bien vous sentez habitées le
problème c'est qu'à l'écran il ya un
truc qui casse un peu le délire et qui
nous empêcher d'y croire complètement
savage unis n'entendent et ma voix rien
que ma voix à jude aux paupières sont
lourdes au chili j il aurait marqué vous
inquiétez pas ces séries qui fait son
malin c'était pareil façon de dire il
faut arrêter que les liners là comme ça
maintenant dans tous les émissions on
explique tout autant les gens seraient
pas assez intelligents pour comprendre
de même regarder
[Applaudissements]
voilà je suis lire repars avec une
voiture bar on s'en doute ça mc syrie
l'atrazine fille dehors juste pour
montrer ce que c'était une twingo
c'est mignon ensuite la vraie mission
paranormal de tp s'était pas jeudi
c'était la veille avec la venue de tania
de ses créditeurs alala alors ça je suis
un taupe aurel d'accord mais je voulais
revenir parce que j'adore les bananes et
j'adore gagner mais que voulez protéger
les baleines
non mais les deux mais non mais beaucoup
de gens étaient surpris par le fou rire
de benjamin pour un clip de tania ça à
ces attentes ont cru qu'ils se moquent
et ça ça fait un mini buzz sur les
réseaux sociaux
comme quoi il ya des vrais débats et ben
c'est pas du tout ce qu on croit alors
j'ai cherché le départ du fou rire et en
fait ça a rien à voir avec notre invité
du soir ça s'est passé pendant les
quatre tiers et malheureusement je suis
pour rien non plus dans cette joie
excessive de benji en fait pour
comprendre il faut savoir qu'en ce
moment si une recrute une nouvelle
chroniqueuse tous les trois jours
pour représenter la ménagère de moins de
25 ans c'est bien ça apporte de la vie
mais nous à côté des fois on est un peu
largué alors quand benjamin a vu
charlotte pironi dans le top gène ans il
a parcouru les fixies juste à côté de
lui mais non c'est non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cape town est ce qu'on peut voir deux
fois la dernière image et bien sûr que
si on peut la juste la dernière image
voilà vous en a marqué au passage que
quand benjamin écrit la fruits il a plu
dieu alors le fou rire ça a commencé
comme ça c'est ça de départ levé sur
j'ai cherché mais le problème c'est
qu'une fois que c'est parti c'est devenu
incontrôlable et à ce moment-là temps a
dit proutat benjamin est sûre se rouler
par terre direct en europe et les samu
donc quand il a vu le clip de tania on
l'avait perdu depuis longtemps et faut
être honnête c'est vrai que la chanson
là je fais
[Musique]
le chic
sur la tête de ma mère jane dans ja
style
beaucoup plaire à fiston
les paroles sont de jean michel béria
qui avait sept jours
dans la glace a dit vous avez qui paie
[Applaudissements]
qui l'a très mal pris un goujat je suis
désolé me fait rire c'est sympa en plus
mes services seront son clip c'est pas
bon pour ibra c'est bon c'est une
transition joyeuse pour le top gênant ça
j'adore cette compilation des petits
moments étranges qui ne se passe que
dans tpm p
[Musique]
m
prenez le mot le plus long de la page
oui tu le comprends voilà et que tu
connaisses
[Musique]
[Rires]
sécurité de tous
bagages
[Musique]
classé
je ne sais pas si vous avez remarqué
mais j'ai pas me maxime nantes objets
dans ce cas oui qu'en fait c'est toute
la semaine de maxime qui a été triste ça
a commencé par un beau moment de
complicité entre lui et son nouveau
voisin gilles verdez ah c'est pas très
chaleureux un élan faut plus pour
décourager la petite racaille du un sens
un peu plus tard il a essayé de faire
ami ami avec gilles en impressionnant
avec son emploi du temps de ministre des
jeunes et devrait faire mieux
alors bien sûr vous allez me dire la
semaine dernière ça n'a pas été que du
malheur puisque il a quand même gagné un
prime maxime rey c'est vrai et
d'ailleurs il nous a tous impressionnés
quand il a refusé d'échanger cette boîte
en finale votre matthieu delormeau
regardez pas cette boîte je la change
dans les mains première gare vous voulez
garder
merci garder cette boîte ont donné cette
boîte
je veux la 9
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faut savoir que ça vient d'étriller
c'est maintenant maxime qui dit qui
doublera jason statham dans tous ses
fils alors autre sujet la semaine
dernière vous m'avez dit que vous aimez
bien les révélations chocs
oui ce terme ont résolu oui est ce que
vous êtes toujours sur cette ligne oui
toujours
vous êtes sûr ben c'est tant mieux le
camp il se passe des choses bizarres à
l'antenne mais le public a le droit de
savoir ce qui se cache derrière tout ça
s'étant jamais dû sortir mais tant pis
voici le deuxième numéro des dossiers
secrets de tpm p
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
pas du tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya des caméras et c'est aussi méchant
méchant didier je suis dit ouf
[Musique]
les mecs n'ont méchant loup et ses mers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous entendez non gérables
il me dit j'ai oublié ce truc là je dis
moi aussi je crois que le plus
consternant dans cette séquence et
géraldine maillet qui est censée être la
plus intelligente de tous les mandats
si l'ue 10 janvier chez lui répond c'est
parce que tu es debout ça fait quoi
comme d'habitude j'ai décidé que les
gens sont debout il envie d'y être sympa
le marathon de paris va bien passer à
tous qu'on n'aurait pas voulu voir ou
entendre cette semaine dans l'émission
et ça commence par maxime guinea joue du
piano
le problème c'est qu'il n'a pas de piano
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le deuxième album sortira le 26 janvier
vient on s'aime c'est le single tu
reviendras pour l'album
j'espère que tu as une excuse j'ai
jamais dis que ça sortait le 26 janvier
et ben voilà du groupe vont devoir faire
ainsi à l'homme à l'animal sachant que
scarlett et une intelligence d'un enfant
de trois ans et demi et elle qui
commence et c'est à dire un mot sur
pagny ou pas oui parce que justement des
extraits de panique parce que brouiller
avec la noix alors regardez la tête donc
florent pagny cassis ma vie dans ma tête
et un médecin qui ne trouvez-vous pas à
sa place ici dans l'émission par exemple
non non je tombe tout le monde à sa
place à la limite c'est moi la plus
vieille république
[Musique]
c'est une horreur géraldine maillet a
pas pris une goutte d'eau sans décote
sais-tu vous avez un peu le pantalon
mouillé quand même
[Applaudissements]
elle nous a fait une justin bieber est
tunisien c'est justin beiber fashion
week alors je m'étais dit je vais
changer un peu je vais faire un peu
fashion week
je gémis keaton
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et marshall
le lou peut le pool le danton qui a été
oh ça va on n'arrête pas de me régaler
vieille couilles
[Applaudissements]